call of duty infinite warfare will take
players on an unforgettable journey as
they engage in heroic battles on earth
and beyond our atmosphere against a
relentless enemy group that threatens
our ideals and way of life this is a
classic story of good vs evil with
large-scale war visceral combat and all
new gameplay experiences afforded by
expanding the scope of action into the
vastness of space infinite warfare is a
true passion project for all of us it's
the game we've always wanted to make we
believe it's something new and special
that fans have never seen before in
order to deliver on that vision we
placed a huge focus on storytelling
stories at the heart of every great game
so we're putting our all into it our
campaign unfolds through a single
protagonist he plays lieutenant Reyes a
tier 1 Special Operations pilot in the
unsa field promoted to captain following
a brutal massive sneak attack on earth
in the midst of a fleet week parade the
footage you're about to see is from the
opening sequence of the game and picks
up shortly after the attack has begun as
lieutenant Reyes you must take the reins
and lead your squad through the
destruction and debris to push back
against the enemy on behalf of everyone
here at the studio thank you and enjoy
we are getting breaking news out of
Switzerland eva has suffered a massive
grupa stay close keep moving to the
tower he's good take point lead us up I
share civilians overhead hold your fire
you okay sir get yourself to safety get
off the street head indoors left office
there
you hearing that something's in coming
closer
ah
cons are still done sir ADA's towers
dead ahead we're getting close c-section
but fine that's great Monica
pick up a back push through
salter take us out Raj this way what's
better
why are they attacking us sir Seth
that's been trying to take control for
years Ethan they knew our whole fleet
with here there's movement inside Reyes
hi that door I'll clear him behind you
let's get out there how come 50 cent
traffic I need your airship drawing fire
at the tower foreground Wars cover clear
sir inbound on let's go through here
tenere get your Jackals in the air for
fire support Roger that sir retribution
this is 11 confident 11 Gator I need
scarf three airborne for interdiction
call for fire to follow up in attending
time to try to get one like Top Cat to
go air is inbound for suppression once
they engage we're taking the tail ok
let's go weapons 3 let's get to the
tower
Wow
oh wow
why 26 make the rice
Rick the hell
let me transport in the air
meeting us out
take it out
jerk hacky
he's down
target destroyed Batman for saw towers
at the top of the hill
getting close hey focus
everyone in position for gun run
one is too much activity need you to
mark the target for me request for fire
target is marked Roger target acquired
inbound
guns out shot down
we shrink bed it's buggin out
let's go Reiter to Maine lieutenant
Salter 93rd 32 an escort to your
position we're down fire changing mag
31 on station available fantastic 31
target marked Roger Payne bouncing gun
guns guns guns
one o'clock gauri disengaging
lieutenants I'm ordering all available
airships into low orbit get yourself
winged up
let's mount up
look what they did to us race let's go
get himself 12 PP she's naked but the
Eclipse your solid scars fold in we're
going upstairs go flight
vodka throttle
Oh
going for one hour
your eyes on this Reyes permanent let's
get in there target i love it love it on
me all scorers and dictionaries
destroyed
burglars
birds
physical damage
sir one set F shaping the AO silicon
the bridge turn occupied
you got injuries
pre-order and get the terminal bonus
snap